Please welcome co-founder and chief executive
officer at Palunteer, Dr. Alex Karp.
[Music] Uh even this working is it working? Even
I find that motivational. It's uh it's pretty
good. I should just sit down. It's like wow. I
don't have anything else to say. But um at at
the risk of regurgitating the one thing here,
it's like that Silicon Valley uh we've been at
odds with Silicon Valley on and off for since our
inception, you know, 20 years ago where we were
essentially patriotic and um that was optional
in Silicon Valley and kind of viewed skeptically.
um being pro, you know, America winning was kind
of like um I don't know, kind of like being into
origami in high school. It's like you didn't get
any dates. People kind of felt sorry for you kind
of vibe. It's like and you're like, "But my my
swan is so beautiful. Why why can't I get why
doesn't anyone love me or even like me or why?"
And um uh but uh and interestingly now we're
largely aligned certainly in private um this is in
private become uh the one place in America uh that
um is really really disproport disproportionately
uh uh showing the world that we can do things that
really don't exist it in the western world like
the the way in which we scale tech, build tech,
create build things creatively. Um, and
it's actually a place where people still
believe in basic uh controversial concepts like uh
meritocracy, agency. Like we actually believe that
you can start off with something that looks crazy
and if you fight really hard and you surround
yourself with highly annoying uh but the most
competent people and that's often correlated. It's
not causation but you could if you were building
Palunteer you could think it's causation. It's
uh somewhere between causation and correlation
um depending on how much sleep you've had. Uh,
and we, you know, literally do not care here
where you were born, where you came from,
what your parents did. We just don't care. And
I, you know, I spent half my life in Europe and,
uh, in Germany, a tremendous intellectual
culture, but yeah, you will more likely end up
uh, where you were born uh, when you're 50 or
60 than any other variable. And that's just not
the case in Silicon Valley. The what what I think
where we're very aligned then though in in in like
became very aligned with our our partners was uh
and I really underestimated this choice by simply
saying we're going to build the product that's
going to make this government agency superior.
And by the way then you know it's like all these
conspiracy things online that like they got us
and it's like it was actually the opposite.
We fought the government. the government.
We actually there were two big things that
led to where we got here. One, we're like,
we're going to build the thing the government
ought to build, which is data protection while
finding the bad person. And that the alpha, it's
very similar to alpha in a business is margin and
growth. It's not one. Alpha in government is not
finding bad person. It's finding bad person while
enhancing civil liberties or at very the very
least making sure those civil liberties are
harder to evviscerate. That's the alpha and but
then the underlying proposition was we are going
to build the whole company around what creates
the most value. Now it was partly because we in
great part because we believed in it. It was also
because we and especially I had the sense no one's
going to buy this product from us unless it's 10
times better because they are not looking at me
and saying you look like me and I'm going to buy
that product. uh uh you know I so and if you build
downstream from value creation you end up with
forward deployed engineers, echoes, deltas, devs,
uh very few trained people and the reason you end
up with forward deployed engineers especially in
the beginning is you have to extend the product
and the product we built in the beginning was
essentially uh how do you enhance uh data
protection and find terrorists in a context where
you don't have LLMs and so you have to use very
primitive of NLP technology. And the the answer
to that is you build this incredibly difficult to
build product with a team of the best engineers I
think anyone's seen in Silicon Valley in decades.
But then even that didn't work. So we had to
have people on the front end who are essentially
engineers extending the product to a place where
the product couldn't go. And why did we do that?
I again those of you who are, you know, I don't
know, over 40 know the punishment of doing that
meant that every single financially trained person
was on the other side of the business because what
did everyone know as a fact? If you're doing quote
unquote services, you have a one multiple. Nobody
wants to invest in a business that has a one
multiple. So, you are screwed. Uh, and in fact,
the fact that everyone thought it was a cult,
we kind of were, was what saved the company
because we were so in our cult, we were like,
"Huh, multiples. We're not interested in that.
We're not going public." So, you know, uh, but but
if you then fast forward to now, what is driving
our business in the US? Like, and it's like, yeah,
of course, we have the best partners. You're the
best partners. Uh, what defines a best partner? A
partner is somebody who is wants to create maximum
value in their business. Uh meaning revenue and
margin shift and everything that is kind of
downstream of that safety goes up, happiness goes
up of employees, workers. You know, one of the
things I do think Silicon Valley is totally effed
up. It's like in overhyping the value of LLMs by
by not listening to our treatises of truth that an
LLM is a raw material that has to be processed and
the processing of the LLM will change America and
change the world. By overhyping the LLM and saying
you're going to have AGI tomorrow when of course
that wasn't what was going to happen. you had to
go adversarial to to workers because you had to
say, "Well, of course you're going to disappear
tomorrow because our LLM doesn't work the way
it should today and isn't is very valuable, but
it's not without an ontology archite architecture
around it to make it predictive, a very unsemingly
powerful predict tool that's built on statistics,
more precise. you had to say the less precise
thing is going to be fully valued tomorrow.
And so instead of doing what it should have done,
which is you can actually transform your business
by being open to different ways of doing business.
And what would that mean? It would mean anywhere
where human ingenuity can be enhanced. Whether
that's the worker, whether that's the person
running something, where the person who's in
charge of a part of their business can take large
language models, use them inside their enterprise.
And what does that mean? It means uh extending the
human mind. It means being able to use the large
language model to change margins, to increase
safety, to increase revenue. And how do you do
that? Well, of course, the model has to interact
with an understanding of your business as it is.
What is your business? It is a concatenation of
your insights, your knowledge of how to run the
business, your competitive advantage, which is
essentially tribal. I know how to do this in a
different way than anyone else. The highfidelity
data sets in your business. Um, and your ability
to orchestrate the large language models outside
of your business while being inside an abstraction
of your business. You would need something like
ontology and foundry. Maybe you could get it from
someone else. And you would need forward deployed
engineers on our side to teach your people how to
be forward deployed engineers because there's a
way in which you still have to extend the product.
So it's it is extending your uniqueness. It is not
making you a commodity. And by the way, this is
where we're aligned against what most people view
as a business cuz we are not building. We want a
non-commodified business. We want a business that
is completely differentiated than anyone else's
so that people struggle to compete to the point
where they just have to complain about you on TV,
which is what happens to us every day. Everyone's
complaining about, you know, it's like, oh, you
know, it's like that's what you want for your
business. And that's exactly what you can get by
taking essentially this very, very important raw
material and using it in a processed form in
your business. And I I think this is why we're
so happy with you and I hope you're as happy
with us as we are with you and why, you know,
we can and I think basically transfer over time
our financials to your financials because we're
doing exactly the same thing. And then what I
personally love about this is it gives a massively
unfair advantage largely to businesses in this
country. Why? Because if you compare corporate
culture in America to any other country, you have
highly dynamic meritocratic structures that are
plastic in the sense that people will move and
change to what works, not what worked yesterday.
It is like Germany is an incredible culture. But
the way in which the corporate structure works is
the whole corporate structure is in charge for
like 30 years. Like it is nearly impossible to
change how you do things. in America, we're like,
you know, what the we're just going to do what
works. And then you have a native essentially this
is a native capacity. It's in America. And that
also makes a is a huge differentiator because de
facto. It's very hard to accept a new way of doing
things if the person explaining it is not rooted
deeply into your culture. And so this like just
completely hypercharges industry. Um now it also
hypercharges government which is why we're doing
very well in government. Although it's worthy of
note whenever people are like Palanteer is doing
too well in government. I was like yeah we are
doing very well but it's 40 points less than how
we're doing in commercial. But any case, what what
makes me really look forward to these conferences
and every time even more is we are fully aligned
with making sure your world looks closer to our
world, which is you're able to radically increase
growth, radically decrease margins, and increase
the happiness of the people in your business
at all levels of business, including workers.
And that is actually the real promise of the AI
revolution. and uh you know and I'm really happy
you're here and then the other you know it's just
like it's incredible to have you know it's easy
for you know like in the end of the day people
are going to think well yeah he's in charge of the
company he's a large owner of course he says that
well again that's why we have people here it's
like one of the things we learned when we built PG
in the beginning was we could run around telling
governments it's the best product or we could
put people in the room and you could talk about
your experiences good bad ugly And and then what
you're doing here is you are actually a change
agent function because in fact you got on the boat
and the reason why I'm grateful to you, you got on
the boat before anyone else. And now everybody's
like, "Huh, I have a bot in my company that's not
really working. I have a piece of software in my
company that was basically you know I don't know
like we every single company we look at there's
like I don't know in at scale there's like a
billion dollars of like duplicative software that
is just a Frankenstein monster lurking in your
company preventing you from doing what you want.
What is it you want to know? I want to know the
cost of goods. I want to know how I'm going to
increase. How am I going to be more efficient?
How do I deal with a a situation where there's
macroeconomic disruption? Like, and and the thing
that's impeding you from that is the software that
is lurking in your system that you somehow can't
take out. And we're going to partner with you to
do that. And you're going to partner with us to
make your company great and occasionally tell us
that tell other people that you we helped you and
that we're not the freak show that people think or
we are. My my favorite compliments in government
were like honestly from the special forces.
They're like, "Man, you guys look really freaky."
And in the beginning, I didn't like you, but
when you save help save my buddy's life, I really
learned to like you. And another lesson in Silicon
Valley is we are able to learn to like people and
partner with people. That in the beginning, we're
not exactly our cup of tea. And we do this as a
culture. It's one of the most underestimated parts
of our culture. American culture learns to like
what works. And that's a very rare quality. Uh
it's very different than like other interesting
great places in the world. We really do learn to
like and value what is working. Not what worked
in the past, not what could work, not what they
say at Berkeley philosophy department is going
to work. not what some crazy person on the right
left aspires to believe could work in a society
where that wasn't differentiated that didn't have
technology that didn't have finance and didn't
have any enemies yeah lots of things work under
those conditions including you know the faculty
lounge at Berkeley but in this world Americans
learn to like and love things that actually
do work and give disruptive value and that's
essentially what we're claiming to do with you as
partners so very happy to have you here. Delighted
and I hope you have a great time. Take care. Bye.